allah he had a different plan not
everybody was against me but the one
many of the ones who were against me
they changed their mind
so i have my mother embrace islam my
father embraced islam two of my aunts
two of my uncles and about 250 of my
cousins
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was waiting on another
to scream again you mean cream
no scream
you
your drink was screaming bro yeah that's
true yeah you just took a cipro on
camera i'll take another one
see bismillah what are you doing well
it's in my head man
like i think there's another thing too
it's it's the perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims podcast
today we're joined with a very special
guest brother ibrahim alaikum
i'm super pumped to be here bro i guys
listen i i may love bless you may allah
continue to preserve you may allah
continue to ex
uh to expand you and elevate you i mean
just
amazing effort you're doing amidst all
the controversy and all the other uh
challenges you're facing you still show
up and to me eighty percent of success
is showing up so congratulations on that
may allah bless you
i'm here i'm ready to serve man talk to
me brother stop let's go bro so most of
the viewers don't know that we got
toronto's finest in the building in the
hot seat today so never did i think that
starting this podcast you know with the
brothers eight months ago that we would
have someone from the city that i grew
up in
right that i've never met and i i just
met you through brother gabriel so going
to the what's your story
uh my story wow gosh uh my story
for for my story i don't know if you
ever seen this movie amazon where the
guy said when he's telling the story he
said he's trying to tell the story and
it's like a little story like this he's
trying to tell but the other guy is
saying no you have to go way back
you have to go all the way back to
africa well my story is like that my
family around 1450
or around that area we don't know exact
dates okay they were taken into slavery
they're african people taking it to
slavery and they become slaves africans
become slaves then they later become
blacks and all this other kind of stuff
okay so they take them they they take
them from africa and what do they do
they take them to the caribbean because
that was the slave catchers and then
from there they took him to the
caribbean which was the slave breakers
and then after that they took him to
america north america and other places
where they became slave traders
this is a business and now what they're
doing is they get the people to do all
the work they're doing the cotton and
doing all the different things in the
field or whatever and they're taking
that stuff and they're taking it and
selling it to europe and when they're
selling it to europe they're selling it
for the highest price and they're going
now to make their their countries rich
and they're doing all kinds of great
business offer the backs of the people i
come from those people
my people who came now from the south of
america came to the north of america
ended up getting uh uh free from the uh
british loyalist people and they were
taken to nova scotia which was british
north america
when that happened they were given they
were given their so-called freedom quote
unquote but when they got to canada
right there was a problem what was the
problem they tried to practice islam
now think about this back in africa they
were muslim
some of them at least guaranteed
when they came now into the caribbean
they were muslim
when they went into the slave traders in
america they're still muslim 300 years
in slavery they're still trying to hold
on to their islam
when they got to canada 1783
when they got to canada they're still
muslim and they're trying to practice
their islam and the people said you
can't do that here this is not
acceptable
put too much pressure on them put them
in serious difficulties that the people
end up going back to africa some of them
were shipped back to africa and then
there was others that actually went back
to the caribbean
in either case they couldn't stay in
canada because again there was no way to
practice the islam
so the children they left from islam and
they became christian
because the parents way to manage it was
we're going to practice islam in the
house but when we go outside we're going
to do all the stuff that the other
people do
the children said no no we're not blamed
that those people have the power you
guys have no power we're joining them
for me i'm the first one to come back
so when i first came back to when i
first came back to islam and i have no
idea about this i have no concept or
understanding of it when i came back to
islam and made
may the 10th 1983
1 45 p.m i'm in toronto don jail
we grew up in poverty
we grew up in a very bad situation we
grew up among gangs and drugs and
violence and crying
it's undeniable the hardships that we
fought but guess what when when i came
into that situation i'm in jail and i
get the message of islam allah send it
to me i didn't i wasn't looking for it i
was criminal man
i didn't think it was a big deal
i didn't know what a big deal it was
that's the truth
and then allah he pulled my coat and
said hey come on over here i'm not done
with you now understand this um we're in
a gang and in our gang there was two of
my members two of the members of my gang
had already been shot by the police
and killed the police came into the jail
saw me there and said okay downey you're
next
now i wasn't afraid of dying
i just didn't want to die for nothing
and that's what i ask allah don't allow
my life to be for nothing
i'm 25 years old i don't just i just
don't want to die for nothing and i ask
allah for three things don't let me die
for nothing
let me do some good with whatever time i
have left and put me around people who
would guide me to the right way
this is after i embrace islam when allah
did like this that was it for me i i i'm
all into islam i'm i'm i'm in that's it
and we changed everything
now
the the the key uh the key element here
is that um the people my family they
came against me and they were fighting
me like crazy for 30 years
30 years don't don't make any joke about
that my aunt and my cousin literally
came to my home here in malaysia
two years ago they came here to my home
and they want to see what my situation
was am i am i leaving from the family
have i abandoned them and all this other
kind of stuff because the way that they
treated me was horrible and i could tell
you some horror stories but we're gonna
leave that for now and may allah guide
them and but here's the thing when they
came they said that my uncle who became
my nemesis the guy who was against me i
mean absolutely against me who was
christian guess what he came now to um
have this idea that when i embraced
islam
that i had turned my back on god
[Music]
yeah yeah you never seen nothing like
that brother
i was i was i was dumbfounded i didn't
know what to say
i was like alhamdulillah but this is our
response
all praises due to allah under all
conditions
but this is what i've done and this is
how i've gone to this thing so we we've
come through all of that and in the
process of coming through all of that al
allah took my a lot of my relatives who
came against me many of them turned
against me and i mean turned against me
man i i mean they
there's no phone calls there was no
connection i mean
it was it was it was very awkward but at
the same time allah he had a different
plan
because again over the years now
not everybody was against me but the one
many of the ones who work against me
they changed their mind
so i have my mother embraced islam my
father embraced islam two of my aunts
two of my uncles and about 250 of my
cousins
people were looking at me and saying you
know what i like your attitude i like
what you're doing i was in charge of the
food bank i was in charge of security i
was doing all kinds of different
activities to help people and do some
good and trying to show what islam had
to offer in terms of islam helping and
muslims helping and putting that stuff
out front
people thought that we were just extreme
people
crazy people who don't really contribute
any good
because the muslims love to take take
take take very little is giving but when
i came i was giving and people saw that
they said okay we want we want a piece
of that we like that
so it changed a lot of stuff
and there's a whole story behind that
that that's just it's it's riveting it i
mean when i started telling my story
people just like wow how did you do all
of that we started talking about like
the muslim inmate program you know and
and and i give my props to my somali
sisters
okay because we started back in when
when the somali women heard that i was
helping the brothers in jail
the men the the women the daughters and
the aunties and all like that they came
in and they just came they would not
leave me alone in the masjid brother
if they saw me in the masjid they just
came brother my uncle is there my father
is here my brother is here my cousin is
here you got to help nobody want to help
so now we had to start a program to be
able to do all of that
only the community the community
wouldn't support it they didn't find
value in it we're on our own
so we had to keep it going by ourselves
with no money from the government we're
not taking their money because if they
give us their money then we know that
they want to be in charge and they're
going to dictate to us what it is our
mandate
yeah
my mandate was only one thing brother
invite the creation back to the worship
of the creation of the creator
finish that's it
so
[Laughter]
um okay that's for me that's what i
could tell you i don't for me i have so
much i want to share i i'm i'm bubbling
with enthusiasm to be able to get this
out you know um last year uh on august
1st
2020 i did uh for the first time i i
have all of this knowledge and all the
stuff i'm gathering up all of these
years but nobody from our family and
nobody in our community in our society
nobody wants to talk about it
so last year uh and i'm begging allah
i'm asking ya la you know
let me get this stuff out let me leave
it as a legacy let me let me leave some
breadcrumbs others can follow
last year they called me up from one
group that said okay we're doing this
story about emancipation day would you
like to join us
black canadian muslim oh i jumped all
over that bad boy
are you joking
oh yeah i was like yeah i'll go
i'll spit let's go
and we dropped it like it was hot it
just for me i just told my story the
same story i'm sharing with you with
more detail i just told them that's what
we did
this is what happened
now the thing that becomes a real
difficulty again there's three things
that that become a difficulty when the
muslims came to canada which was british
north america is that we came here we
were black and were supposed to be free
but the freedom was different and then
people don't want to talk about it but
there's a whole other element that gets
ignored and that's the element of how we
mixed with the native people the first
nation people
we mixed with them
we married them
i'm considered i'm considered my family
is considered um what they call um
uh what do you call it again nathan not
native is it indigenous
indigenous to canada
that's deep stuff
we're indigenous
to the land
so alhamdulillah we we have a certain
status nobody wants to talk about it man
because again the indians are looked at
as very low people and the africans are
looked at as very low people too and it
becomes like a taboo some kind of
embarrassment but the connection is
already there
so
okay
man
yeah yeah
so anyway you got to understand that for
me i'm not popular around a whole lot of
people in canada or my people
i'm not a popular guy
i'm not that's let's just call it what
it is
they prefer they prefer they prefer not
to have me there anyway but i'm okay i
found a place over in in malaysia i
found other places in the world in the
middle east i found other places and i i
found other places
a lot you see allah took my relatives
and he said okay you guys want to be
like that okay you stay like that but
then he opened up the way from me and
gave me a family
family of muslims
go into how you met gabriel in in
toronto because a lot of the viewers
don't know but gabriel is a regular
panelist right so they're going to be
shocked to know that you know him
yeah i know him very well masala him and
i go back probably what 17 18 years now
um for me i i was always busy in the
masjid because again the the number of
muslim youth that was actually going
into the jails it started to increase
from 19 1975
going all the way up or even up until
now the number is going going like crazy
but the reality is that the numbers are
going up but we're not putting anything
in place to be able to to deal with that
or to be able to counsel the people and
then the governments they actually hired
they had some muslims uh chaplains who
they hired and then what they did was
they fired everybody
so i used to go have to go to the masjid
and be able to advise the people how not
to get into problems and how to stay out
of the situations of being involved with
drugs violence crime gangs all this kind
of stuff that puts people in jail
it was scary with the number of people
going to jail was it was scary
and because of that now we we had this
mandate to be able to say uh you know
okay we we have to tackle if there's
nothing else i'm asking the community
members if you don't want to give us any
money okay fine but at least give us the
opportunity to talk to the people and
advise them we have women suffering
their families are suffering the
situation is ugly
our youth are coming now to rob each
other and rob their uncles and different
people like that in the taxis
they're robbing them to be able to get
money to be able to go buy some drugs
now come on at some point in time let us
at least talk about the issues
somehow many of the organizations they
would do that and some of them when they
would see me coming they would say okay
brother you have a chance to talk
we give you 10 minutes okay
let's go let's go let me spit it out
this is what we're doing this is where
we're going
because we're going right across the
country because many people will
remember that it's uh
in toronto and it's in ontario but we
were going right across the country and
then we literally started going right
across the world
for me i don't know if you guys you okay
so sophia you you know regent park yes
yeah
okay so so regent park is one of the
worst places in the city
downtown toronto it is one of the worst
places i i grew up in regent park
so what happened for me i i came now out
of that environment that was my
condition of how i had to live
so now for for me going now to 23
countries around the world
and being able to teach
what i teach
it's it's incredible and it could only
happen by the permission of allah can
you hang on for one second please
have fun yeah i'll be uh yay
um i'm sorry you're asking me something
you lost my train of thought
no worries no more it's just more
details on how you met gabriel arumani
in toronto
um just in uh just hanging around the
people of knowledge and trying to absorb
the knowledge of islam and and um uh
what i remember is that uh we were both
coming out to want to uh absorb uh as
much as we could of the knowledge of
islam not for the sake of the knowledge
itself or just having the knowledge but
about how we could apply it
and how we could make it how we could
use it to make a difference
and this is one of the things i i
understood about him from the early days
is that he was looking to be able to
improve himself but he wanted to also
improve the situation for the people who
would allah would send to him
he had that desire so when he came to uh
when he came to malaysia i didn't know
i came to malaysia maybe five years ago
and i think he may have been here before
me or maybe just after me but either way
when i came here i was only coming i was
coming here to check out some business
opportunities
i was doing some things back in canada
that were creating money for me but at
the same time um i had had a lot of good
friends one of my friends was dr bilal
phillips i think you guys probably know
him
yes
okay him and i have been best friends
for the longest time and um uh
him and i met back in jammie mosque in
boosted avenue in toronto i used to sit
down and the brother in the in the
bookstore i was so poor when i left when
i left from the
you know when i left from the street
back in the day
uh i was so poor man
you got to understand for me one minute
man i had like two apartments man i had
a computer when the computers weren't
even a thing it was a paperweight for me
i didn't know you had to turn it on
manny you could you had to put the clear
the screen that was what i knew clear
the screen you had to put in the dos
codes and all that kind of
it was a long time ago but um that's
that was crazy stuff we had cars we had
places we had this and that and whatever
have you but it was it was all uh
it was all phony
i didn't know it at the time because
that's the only thing that i understood
that's what i related to but once i
understood once once i came into islam
then i wasn't going back to it
and i used to literally sit in the
bookstore and this guy who's running the
bookstore a brother named ali bash not
sure if he's still alive if he is may
allah bless him and if he's not may
allah bless him
because
this brother used to be so kind to me he
allowed me to sit in the bookstore and
literally he would hand me books so i
would find books i wanted to read and i
would be able to sit down on the floor
and read them
because i didn't have money to buy it
i barely had money to be able to take a
ticket going back and forth and i'd
hoped that i would get a little bit of
brienne or some samosa or something like
that to eat before i went back home
so it was deep stuff and then he was
giving me these books from dr bilal
phillips then one day dr bilal comes in
he says oh that's the guy i said what do
you mean he said yeah this is the guy
who writes the books
but then he was writing books that were
controversial he was reading a book
called the um
the uh the answer allah cult
i don't know if you remember that or
even seen it but the answer is what
the answer the answer allah
called there was this group of people
who are calling themselves they answer
allah the the helpers of allah they're
calling themselves like this right and
uh but they were calling yourself also
the nubian islamic hebrews
and they were a cult and they were
saying that they represented islam and
they would stand on the they would stand
on the street with the thobes and the
kufis and not kufi's even they would
have on turbines and they look like
muslim you couldn't tell anything until
they started telling you about their
deen
and when they started talking about they
had a whole twisted idea about how islam
was going and he he dismantled them took
them apart
just dismantled them and they got very
angry and they wanted to do something
and they were threatening him and for me
it's real simple for me what him and i i
fell in love with the brother by the
knowledge he was sharing but he also
took shahada in toronto a long time
before back in the 1970 i think was 1972
so when him and i came now to be like
that i was like nah man if you guys do
anything to him you deal with me
and people understood what that meant
like for me i had a i had a reach that
could go far
i was one of those guys who wasn't
afraid to use it if need be but again i
came away from that life
but it's not like you know i mean you
can take the boy out of the hood but you
can't take the hood out of the boy
some of you guys know better than others
i see you smiling
[Laughter]
so yeah so um again i was looking for
opportunity man because uh for me i was
the um
i was the
uh
director for
islamic online university uh dr phillips
started the islamic online university
and it was giving people a chance to get
islamic knowledge up to ba
for free
and it was all over the world
but again he took a lot of heat from
that and there was some difficulty being
able to keep it going but he did and
it's still going
so may allah bless him and i hope you
pray for him because he's doing he's
doing a very noble and impor important
thing
so
yeah so actually he introduced me to to
my wife
and i was just coming to look at a
business opportunity but as soon as we
met it we knew that we were destined to
do something together
but my mom had died before i came here
and um my mom had died in 2010 and then
my life literally was going downhill
and uh it got to the point where in 20
2014 i want to for me i always wanted to
be a lawyer
i don't know if you get this man but i
i'm a good talker
i feel i'm a good talker i could spit
you know i ca i got a few things i can i
can share and um
um i was discouraged all the time coming
through school they were discouraging me
oh you don't want to be a talker you
don't want to be a lawyer no black
people don't become lawyers they become
something else be a handyman get a job
in this place work in a gas station all
this kind of thing i always wanted to be
a lawyer
so
in um
my efforts to become a lawyer i i went
and i went to 1995 i went to uh
university of toronto i wrote my elsa
i passed and i got accepted into law
school in delhi university in nova
scotia one of the best if not the best
law school in in canada
right
yeah yeah and i got accepted and i had
the full scholarship all i had to do was
get from toronto to halifax
and i was in
and
just as i'm getting ready to go one of
my younger brothers he dies from drug
overdose
it's over
my mom she started freaking out that was
her youngest son
she asked me to bury my brother
now i'm muslim and i gotta i for me and
she knows that she can ask me anything
and if it's not against islam i have to
comply
she used that against me more times
but she she understood it that i would
have to comply so i did
so now i'm getting ready to to get ready
to vote you know i want i called the
university it's okay i'm gonna take some
time they said no problem take your time
you can come when you're finished now
i'm getting ready to go
my two brothers they got into a very
silly argument
who can do more drugs the younger one
and the older one they got into argument
who can do more drugs i'll do more drugs
than you no i'll drink more than you and
they're going back and forth like this
they bought twelve hundred dollars worth
of drugs they sat down did it all the
next morning the youngest one he end up
dying from a fixation his his whole
system just regurgitated himself and
came out of his ears his eyes his nose
his mouth and covered his face like an
airplane mask
he died a horrible that
affixie had just booked and done can't
breathe
the next one it took him 10 weeks to be
able to commit um suicide by drug
overdose
for grieving for his brother
so again i couldn't leave my mom asked
me to not leave to go back
so it wasn't until she passed away that
i decided okay i'm gonna go back and try
again because i still want to be a
lawyer
now here's the thing when i go back in
2014 i'm getting ready to i'm getting
ready again i wrote my lsat i passed
right
this is crazy right i'm thinking okay
i'm getting ready now everything's
opening up and so like that except i go
now and i start teaching about my
sibkkis program
and when i'm teaching about that the
professor
i'm writing on his board in the
classroom i'm taking a course while i'm
waiting for their termination
their determination and the professor
there he sees what i'm teaching and
literally tells me that he's going to
recommend that they not take me into law
school
i said why i didn't do anything to you
why would you be that he said no this
what you what you're teaching is
actually more powerful than if you go to
law school and you're going to go for
like the next three to five years what
you're teaching actually you can go into
you can go into the world right now and
teach that to the people it'll bring
more benefit
that's the stuff that i want to share
with you guys today do we have time can
i take 10 yes can i take 10 minutes and
and blow that out yes
if you if you don't mind because
i'm excited man for me i'm excited for
you because we got some stuff that you
guys wouldn't see normally and i mean
uh okay let me just put it like that so
um can i share my screen is that part
always always give me one sec please and
thank you
and i know this is a little bit
unorthodox but again this is uh
this is uh this is the coming together
i'm feeling this synergy man where one
plus one equals all of us
uh no i'm looking for the actual um
presentation let me just pull i think i
have to pull it up first and then after
that i can get it i if i don't pull it
up first it doesn't just come by itself
see i'm working on one here this is
about suicide i i do these presentations
and uh we have a bunch of stuff we're
talking about marriage too you got to
get to see the stuff i'm doing on
marriage
i hope that we can do just a show on
that
it's pre-marriage pre-marriage for the
brothers and the sisters
i mean let's start the conversation
okay um hold on let me see uh
here it is here yes
okay good i got it and let me see
share screen
thank you very much
and uh
where is it where is it where is it
uh
[Music]
okay i think this is it let me see
there we go
okay yes it's not but i gotta go here
okay wrong okay this is wrong i gotta go
back
okay here's we go
i put this together just for you guys
okay fellas seriously just just to honor
the effort you're making man you guys
are doing a tremendous job and there's a
lot of controversy out there to me
there's a lot of confusion
but you're encouraging the people to
come back and to understand what they
could do with their islam and how to get
on track with it well if we're not going
to help each other do that
we're creating our own problem
so for me uh for me uh my company is
called sipkis are the the programs that
we have is called sipkis the empowerment
counseling is called sipkis see it big
keep it simple
big problems simple solutions coming
from
islam and i'm helping empower the lives
of the people who are ready
one decision at a time because you have
to make a decision to work with me
otherwise if you're not going to show up
it's not going to work
okay
and okay moving forward i i want okay oh
hold on let me go back because again
people need social proof
can you guys see this you can see my
screen yeah
okay
this is me this is the first time that
the ontario government has ever
presented anything like this to any
muslim from any community okay
coming out to be able to do this kind of
thing this is for 18 years of
outstanding volunteer remember volunteer
service toronto west detention center
we weren't taking their money and
there's a whole bunch of stuff you can
read on the left as well but we're not
getting into that right now so just for
your social proof you understand that in
over there i i have qualifications and a
certain amount of respect and status
that's undeniable
all right
this is my mom and my dad
my dad my mom she embraced islam the day
i came back from hajj
masha'allah that was february the 8th in
february february the 8th uh 2004.
my dad uh two years later my dad on um
11th of 11th uh 14th of 11 2006
he uh no 14 no not 14 it was uh
11 11 2006 he embraced islam on his
deathbed he never got up from this bed
he died on this bed
but when they came to him to go and
visit him he said what do i have to do
i said what do you mean he said how do
how do i come now to be part of your
religion for 24 years he fought me
with the rest of my family fought me
unbelievably not physically anymore
because i had skills now i was a martial
artist but now after that he came now to
tell me he wanted to become part of the
religion so i tell him repeat after me
and he did he said is that it yeah he
said let's do it again i said what he
said just to be sure
wow
when my mom heard this story when i told
my mom this story she literally got up
from her seat and she literally got me
to take her all the way out to where my
dad was and she came now to go and plant
this kiss on his cheek
for what to heal his heart and to let
him know that she was
forgiven because the way he treated us
back in the day was not kind it's not
easy brother
so again you want social proof when you
people are coming to tell me that
they're having a hard time and they've
been through some hardship okay i've
been through some hardship too but i
found some ways to get around it and get
over it and how to how to figure it out
and if you allow me then i'll share that
with you you see so we focus on three
things with our sip kids counseling
personal financial and social counseling
these are the three things we help
people move themselves into the age of
responsibility we're not moving them i'm
not trying to get anyone to move
anywhere i'm just inviting them to come
and see what's going on for me i've
already made my commitments and i'm
showing other people how they can do it
okay your mind is a garden
and your thoughts are like seats you can
grow flowers or you can grow weeds
it's up to you
but if you don't have the right mindset
you automatically got a problem you
create your own problem for yourself
okay so for me the the realization of
how to help people um make progress in
the world is to help them with their
abcs just like you would do in school
but the abc is attitude belief and
commitment
if you can come now
to understand and adopt that to accept
that then you can actually make leaps
and bounds so quickly in terms of your
own progress and your own empowerment
right but there's two things you need to
believe in yourself
number one you need to believe in
yourself because it's the first key to
to success
and the second thing is you need to have
a mentor and the two people together
they have to make an agreement they say
deal i see agreement that they're going
to help each other be the best versions
of themselves
this is how we talk this is how we
create the healthy relationships does
that make sense
hello
yes
okay this is my favorite this is my
famous my famous uh example i'm gonna
try to give you the quick version of it
so forgive me for that okay but where
would you care to position yourself uh
if you could take screenshots please
take screenshots
if you don't do anything else i i will
tell you take this screenshot because
i'm sharing this information with you
and it's with you in your possession but
you don't own it
you won't own it until you share it with
somebody else
so where would you care to position
yourself for your future
everybody who wants to be above the line
where you learn above the line you learn
below the line you blame everybody who
wants to be above the line please raise
your right hand
i can feel there's a lot of red hands
going off okay
okay so alhamdulillah allah may allah
may allah bless us to be among those
people who stay in that condition how
come we didn't choose blame
i want to show you why because again i
believe in breaking it down like a
fraction
and we've learned it so now if we take
the blame game we need to know that the
blame game is tricky and it turns into
something else and what happens now is
it it uh becomes now a thing that
cripples people
and it when it changes into something
else people don't even hardly notice it
but when it changes it has an impact but
then again you keep on doing it and then
it doesn't the impact isn't felt so if
you understand
the uh if you cover the first letter of
the word blame you will see what happens
and how it changes
it becomes a thing where people get
crippled
emotionally financially academically
romantically socially i mean there's all
kinds of ways to get crippled
so the blame game changes into the lame
game
and sometimes people don't even realize
the devastation of that
and the reality is that the blame game
changes into the lame game because
they're not taking responsibility like
with one finger pointing out when you
got three fingers pointing back
one finger deflecting responsibility
three fingers telling you to take
responsibility if you can't understand
it's a three to one ratio you're already
in trouble
but if you cover the first three letters
of the word blame you'll see who it is
that you have to be responsible for
oh yeah
yeah so we want to spend a lot of time
above the line for the people who said
they want to be above the line we spend
after this it's everybody above the line
let's go right because again if you
cover the first letter of the word learn
guess what you get to do
you get to earn
and then we start talking about how
you're going to earn the blessings of
allah how you're going to earn the
agenda that allah has held out for us
and so on and so forth like that moving
forward okay so you you got to
understand that you're not stuck you're
just committed to certain patterns of
behavior because they helped you in the
past now those behaviors have become
more harmful than helpful
and the reason why you can't move
forward is because you're applying old
formulas
to new levels in your life
change the formula and get a different
result
and here's the reality of that
you were given this light because you're
strong enough to live it
allah does not give any soul a burden
greater than it can bear
it is not going to start with you or me
so let's just make sure that we put that
in our heads and let it go to our hearts
so we can get up and do something that
changes our lives in the way that we
want to need you see we got to remember
why we're here why are we here only for
the worship of allah
that's it finnish palace
allah only created us for that
circumstance of worship
if we're living up to our potential we
got to stay on top of this and make sure
that this is it
so
here's the thing how do we hold on
to uh putting first things first
we need to hold on to the rope of allah
and we must be doing it as as a
community as family and we got to do we
got to do it ourselves hold on to the
rope and we got to help others and we
especially we want to start with our own
family for me that's what i did
i'm not trying to tell people go and do
it with everybody in the world it's
great if we do it with everybody but
especially if we do it with our family
we have a lot of issues with our with
our families and a lot of issues with
the muslim youth we need to be able to
try to deal with some things okay we
know we need to go and again this is one
of the things i did in the middle east
we did a number of presentations where
we literally they were blown away by
this presentation where we literally
would show them that uh where we go from
me
for me my my journey my i had an
incredible journey in islam but my
journey was a simple thing because i
literally went from me to we
as a muslim
and i realized and i accepted that we
are one we are one um um
we are one ummah what are we gonna do
with that
we do something with it we don't do
something with it it's up to us but we
are one we're one ummah that's it
finished
can we be brothers and sisters for real
this is our challenge but we literally
have to take the journey that goes from
me to we to be able to make the changes
that we keep talking about that we think
are good they're good ideas but they're
not going to work until we actually have
these
obstacles uh removed
you see let's talk about the individual
and what it takes to get here because
again i think that many times people
don't come now to recognize and value
the circumstance of what it what
contributions and sacrifices other
people have made
for each person who's called me now to
to be here right now it this is what
you're this is what your your downline
of your of your your generations looks
like you have two parents four
grandparents eight great grandparents
you had the 16 great-great-grandparents
and so on and so forth all the way down
this is going 15 levels deep
this doesn't apply to some people it
applies to everyone
but many times if we don't recognize
this and we don't actually give due
respect and consideration to this guess
what we just blow past this like it's no
big deal
when this is actually a technical thing
that is actually the biggest deal to be
able to make sure that these people get
the respect but we should also be
praying for them to especially the ones
who were muslim and allah knows best who
they were
that's another story we can get into
that okay you see one of the main
problems that we find in in the muslim
community i found in my years of coming
out to serve the the community is that
we repeat what we do not repair
if we don't fix it we just keep doing
the same thing
and that's that's called insanity albert
einstein said that you repeat the same
action over and over again
looking for a different result this is
called insanity
we repeat what we don't repair if we
don't fix it it keeps on coming back it
keeps on coming back and we keep on
trying to apply the same thing this
creates big problems and lots of
confusion we're not making progress with
that
okay
now we get to the part where i'm really
excited to be able to share with you you
see we have to show people how to
negotiate the valley of doom
in troubled times
you know we're coming out to be in a
case where we're covered the world is
covered with this whole covert thing
we have all kinds of challenges jobs
they're lost industry's gone all the
different things with monetary stuff too
many things so now we have a situation
where your life is going along and the
red line is representing life
and what happens now is that sometime in
your life you run into a thing called
the mess
difficulty comes
hardships there's no do there's no two
ways around it you can't get past it and
then what you got to do is you've got to
go through a process of learning
if you don't you get stuck
you choose to get stuck by not learning
this is a big issue right and in order
to get that learning to actually work
you got to take some uncomfortable
action
and what happens many people get to the
edge of this
um
of the journey of uh the journey
of the on the valley of doom and they
get right to the edge and they're about
to fall in for me i was right on the
edge and allah pulled me back and said
i'm not done with you
he said you don't fall into the into the
valley of doom take the bridge the
bridge is called faith
the bridge is called taqwa the bridge is
called iman
take the bridge
for me i took the bridge
and on the other side of the bridge i
found solutions on the other side of the
bridge i
was able to develop a certain skill set
on the other side of the bridge i was
able to have a certain mastery of how to
come down to negotiate the different
things that were going on and help
myself and help other people develop
what they wanted for their future to get
away from the valley of doom or
destruction or depression or
disobedience or disbelief or even death
we can call it all of those things they
all apply
and this is the kind of stuff that i
want to show you because again this is
the kind of stuff that i feel that our
community needs and we need to have more
access to
this kind of teaching to help people get
through their problems we're muslim and
we're not supposed to be able to feel
that we're stuck
people should not feel that we're stuck
because again islam has the solutions
and i'll give you an example i know i'm
talking a lot but i feel so excited to
be here i feel so honored and i'll tell
you one day there's a young man in the
jail and we're doing this program and he
comes to me says brother ibrahim after
the program he says uh you said that
islam has
solutions for any problem
you believe that anybody believe that
besides me
i said yeah right i told him yes he says
okay so where do we find that in the
quran
okay
i said if you look in surah 103
in the quran you will find exactly what
you're looking for
what is allah saying
yes
verily mankind is in a state of loss
except for those who what
believe
do good deeds speak the truth remain
patient
anyone who applies those four things to
their life into their lifestyle will
come now to resolve the issue
that's been my experience
so we want to encourage people to
understand that that islam is there for
the human being to be able to do that
and if you're muslim then that's even a
greater bonus for you but apply those
four things believe in allah
do good deeds speak the truth and remain
patient
you see so we got to be planting seeds
of faith with hope for a better tomorrow
seriously we i i don't know if you
for me this is this is how i think this
is how i live this is i'm grateful to
allah behind all of this and we have to
show people and help them
really get to the idea that they need to
exercise good decisions
that help them
choose the dean over the dunya but many
times there's a problem because there's
a balancing act between what you're
feeling in your head and what you're
feeling in your heart
and sometimes people they mess up and
they don't get it right
and we got to get people to take every
opportunity that they can every day as a
new chance
to be a better muslim
every day not sometimes
and then we want to make sure that
people understand that every day you're
in a battle the battle is not with
anyone else or any other thing or
something like that it's a battle
against yourself this is me against
myself
how are you going to be a better person
than the person who you wore yesterday
this is about mindset and again to have
the proper mindset you got to make sure
that you're making dua what is dua you
understand that you're making dua you're
praying to allah but you understand that
you're depending on allah alone just
like the bird depends on allah
as we've been told by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
okay so take five uh before five what is
that your youth before your old age
you're held before your sickness your
wealth before poverty your free time
before you're preoccupied and your life
before your death
hold on to the rope of allah
we can get into this this is this is an
excellent thing to do but the whole idea
in the concept is hold on to the rope of
allah because it eventually leads to
jannah and then allah we ask him oh
allah make our future better than our
past
oh allah make our graves better than our
houses
make our deaths better than our lives oh
allah make jenna to fordos
our final destination
subhanallah
may allah may he shower us with patience
and let us die as muslims
you see
when people get into problems and we are
we're going to have problems we
encourage people and we we literally
uh we advise them to do what just say la
hallo
and make it moist on your tongue
continuously
look and see that allah's hand will come
to you and his hand if you look for
allah's hand if you allow allah's hand
to come into things you will start to
see allah's hand in everything
why because truly we
belong to allah and we're going to
return to him
this is guaranteed there's no two ways
about it nobody can deny this truth
that's my presentation
masha allah that was like life-changing
subhanallah because you kept mentioning
uh sebastian it's something you've never
seen before and i was like you know
you're really building up my appetite
here it's found allah and but the
president presentation itself masha
allah
it's it's not just one thing it's like a
series of principles that you need to
adopt and it's like it's like the
formula basically so
this
i believe if muslims especially youth
myself and others if they actually
implement these things insha'allah they
will actually properly become leaders
for the community insha allah brother i
appreciate you saying that and i and i
thank you for saying that and uh for for
me i'm here in i'm here in malaysia i've
taken time back from from being if i was
in canada even now they're still calling
me from canada brother do this and
brother do that can you help me in there
so i'm still coming out to advise them
but i'm coming now to take some time
over here to be able to figure out how
we can actually create an institution
even if it's online that allows people
to do exactly what you're saying and
actually learn how can we teach them
because the teaching is the key and then
after that it's about the reaching out
how can we make that kind of thing
happen when we get people focused me i'm
not i'm not this big sheik or this guy
who's got all the credentials from
medina university but i've been to
medina university but i didn't i didn't
go there to learn or anything i just
visited there when i made hajj
but i helped three other people go over
there to medina they became shakes no
problem
i helped seven of my cousins go to uh to
egypt and other places in the world to
be able to learn arabic and be able to
study islam
they're doing good something like that
alhamdulillah
so we continue to do the things that we
can do but again we're doing it in in a
skitty scatter way
we're not coming now to converge
everything together and create a a place
and a condition under which people can
use it as a platform to go from here to
there to be able to go ahead and do it
and i'm only talking about the the the
mindset the mindset training we're not
i'm not talking about the islamic
training and all the different things
that people want from
getting their ba and all that kind of
stuff i think that that stuff is great
but if it doesn't help people if they
get all the knowledge and it doesn't
help them to change the way that they
behave
then that knowledge doesn't have the
right impact yeah
it's good to say we got it but it's not
having the impact and that impact is
what changes
yeah but my example by my experience so
and anyway allah knows
so
anyway uh i'm i'm so happy for you guys
to give me this time jazakallahu this is
this is so amazing
the pleasure is all ours
that was an amazing presentation and i
think because what they do at the
institution that i'm learning at and
teaching now alhamdulillah is they have
interactive classes so
just just make interactive and teach
people this as their teacher make a
group chat where they can ask questions
ask them questions during the class and
that is going to like do wonders for
them inshallah yes
well i want i want to do this kind of
stuff for the muslims
for me brother islam was robbed from me
and my people for
generations maybe four or five
generations was it was ripped out from
them yeah
me coming back i i became the most hated
person i mean they they threatened to do
harm to me but i knew how to fight and
if you fight me then you know i can i
can at least give myself a chance
but they threatened also my children
brother
oh
that's how bad it was
they came now to try to do everything
they could to try to humiliate me and
provoke me and try to
to make me make a mistake
to slip
wow
for me i i got to the point where
literally and i'm not saying this to
show off or anything for me i had to say
to myself i refuse to lose
either i win or i learn
now have you heard that have you heard
this saying that
winners never quit and quitters never
win
yeah
yeah you've heard that you guys heard
that before yeah it's a good thing right
okay but but here's the thing one of the
things that i learned is that winners
never quit
and
quitters never win because quitters
refuse to learn
[Music]
yeah nobody ever thought about why
aren't they winning they could win but
they don't why don't they win they
refuse to learn yeah
thanks
yeah inshaallah
we should take time to learn we should
make that a part of what we're doing and
make sure that we get to learn and then
we start to get to earn like for me one
of the things that has become really
important and relevant is that
we've come now into a different um a
different reality in the world when it
comes to finance
and i'd love to have a chat with you
guys about what's going on in in the
world of crypto
because the world of crypto has changed
everything
and now we've not only come into the
world of crypto but we come into the age
of responsibility
so what if you could be your own bank
and the people in the bank cannot hold
your wealth you can hold it all by
yourself and can control that
see this is the kind of stuff that we
need to start having some discussion
about we need to be able to organize
that thing to be able to give people the
ability to empower themselves
how are they going to come now to be in
a situation where they're going to keep
doing the same thing over and over and
over again we see it didn't work 2008
showed us
2010 they did it again
2020 they did it again how many
breakdowns they're gonna have of the
system and we keep sitting there
expecting the system's going to change
the system's not going to change
and i'm not putting down the system i'm
just simply saying it's not working but
we can take it into our own authority
and we can make the the moves that we
want if we're willing to put in that
kind of con
commitment
but it again it's about to learn and
earn
so i hope we can have a chat about that
one day
and i know i hope i didn't i hope i
didn't uh wear out my welcome here
no no no not at all not at all
very good
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah um
you guys you guys are literally um you
guys are literally um
this this is me
if anyone tells you okay did you ever
meet abraham downey for me what i was
doing back then i'm still doing now
i've just found new ways and and develop
new understandings and been able to you
know for me i i'm gonna say this but i
don't want people to take it wrong but
for me i've learned to lie cheat and
steal
okay but no no no don't smile
brother said please don't sit out on our
show no no but you gotta understand what
i'm saying your content
what am i saying i said you know to lie
in my bed and think about all the ways
that i can prove things improve things
to make things better for muslims to
please allah
okay i i like and i i cheat i cheat i
cheat every moment away from those
things i love to do hanging out with my
family going for walks on the beach the
beach is spread across here i love the
beach but for me i spent a lot of time
doing research on how i can be better
and then on top of that in doing the
research we steal
i steal every opportunity i can to be
able to take what i can to be able to
use it and much of what i shared with
you today is coming from those things uh
that i've been able to lie cheat and
steal
my shot in a good in a good way yeah
[Laughter]
the thing is
things are not as uh things are not
always as they seem
yeah
you know and if you if you really want
to understand some things about money go
look at the hidden secrets of wealth the
hidden secrets of money
it's on youtube for free go check it out
all right we'll do insha allah the
hidden secrets of money yeah yeah i
would advise everyone to see that but
this is the kind of stuff that we need
to have access to so that we can start
changing and uh adjusting and and start
to um
i say rethink the way that things are
being done
yeah
because there's someone there's some
other people besides me who are going to
want to lie cheat and steal
episode guys if you made it this far
comment down below hashtag bring back
ibrahim
for our next episodes inshallah
where can people find you
right now
if you go through
okay it depends on what you want me for
if you're calling me
if you're calling me just a chat i'm not
doing a whole lot of chatting i'm very
very busy uh we have training uh
activities going on in a number of
different areas uh my wife is uh very
much uh active and uh she's dealing with
a lot of logistics for some of the
businesses that we're operating and with
the different activities like that i'm
doing a lot of personal empowerment
training uh online uh with gabriel and
with the things so i guess that would be
the way to be able to do it but yeah
many people would have to want to take
um
uh i say an appointment for a session
with me i think it's cost 35 or
something like that
and uh um to to get uh like an hour of
my time so that we can actually make it
make it a committed hour otherwise than
that i i have i have my commitments man
if you if you understand the stuff that
i'm we're doing stuff brother for me i
i'm i'm um
i've literally
i'm all in to the idea and the
understanding of how to help muslims
develop the uh an empowerment mindset
because we keep on talking about the
same things over and over and over again
but nothing's changing yeah but we need
things to change other people are
changing
the conditions are changing what
happened in afghanistan it changed the
world now these are this is one country
that that expelled two superpowers and
we're not paying attention
come on man don't be so broke you can't
pay attention
we had one country muslim country that's
expelled two superpowers
that can't be ignored we should be
paying attention brother things are
changing and they're changing rapidly
now and we have to kind of find a way to
be able to help people get the right
thinking so that we can make the right
moves and make the right progress
otherwise we're going to be the ones
behind
yeah yeah that's very true that's very
true subhanallah a lot of muslims
nowadays they just assimilate with the
with the culture much like you know
you're saying you're saying the
generations before you that's what they
did they assimilated with the people the
non-muslims and subhanallah it's crazy
because we do that and we think it's the
norm we can't don't even question it so
we have to really like rewire like take
everything apart rewire the people's
brains and shut allah so may allah make
it you know feasible
yeah it becomes so it becomes an issue
of survival lackey like for my people
for my people it became a matter of
survival yeah they couldn't survive in
the environment where they were if it
was they tried to stay strong with their
islam so some of the aunties and the
people who were coming out there they
were honest with me they say that um
yeah we used to be muslim but islam
didn't help us
and that's why they left
okay
so i'm still the most hated man among my
people
i mean there's a whole i mean we're i'm
telling you it's like 200 people embrace
islam we have like we have like 20 000
or more
there's more than not even
okay no and where i come from in nova
scotia where the largest black community
in canada
it's called north preston
founded in 1784 because we landed there
in 1783
1784 we established ourselves as a
community
this is all documented this part of what
i was going to share with you but again
it was like 50 slides we'd still be here
[Laughter]
so i said no no let me let me show for
me i thought it was more it was
advantageous to show you sipkis
i hope that you would fall in love with
sipkis the whole concept and idea of
sipkis is to be able to see a big
problem and then find simple solutions
with islam
if we can get that across to the people
brother this is i mean this is where the
rubber meets the road
yeah in terms of getting people to turn
their lives around and actually making
their progress they need
to to make the changes
but that's been my experience
now
this has been
amazing
anything you want to say before you wrap
up bro you know i was going to say um
it's beautiful the
whole sip kiss thing because when you
first came on here and i i saw your
thing you said ibrahim powered by sipkis
i was like oh he forgot to that's
probably his phone carrier he forgot to
take that off oh no i didn't forget
nothing but yeah no i'm doing that
hungry enough yeah yeah no no it's
abraham downey powered by simkus yeah no
the stuff that powered me brother i come
from the ghetto aki you know what that
is
i come from the ghetto man i come from i
come from nowhere
my life was at risk and i was under i
was under threat of death
and it was legitimate
so for me now to actually be in a
condition where i'm even talking to you
and sharing with you all the stuff that
we've been doing all of these years
we're doing this all around the world
for all of these years brother
and you know if you you know when i tell
you to go take the bridge understand
this is that that you there is no bridge
unless you put in islam
yeah yeah
i just hope you
i hope you get that man
there's no bridge without islam you
can't get to i couldn't get to the other
side
yeah
did you get stuck
yeah yeah i'd be stuck
yeah yeah and and here's the problem
with going into the valley of doom is
that when you get in the valley of doom
people start people start digging trying
to dig their way out of the valley of
doom but the more you dig the deeper it
goes yeah
so what's what's
what do you got to do stop digging
but people that get in there say no no i
gotta get out i gotta get out they keep
digging and digging and digging you know
um you know we have this thing is that
um
um
you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make him drink
yeah what you can do you've heard that
too right yeah
okay but what you can do is you can
entice that horse
what you can do is you can give that
horse some oats you let it eat before it
gets while it's in a piece where you can
give it some oats and you put inside the
oats just a little bit of sugar a little
bit of salt
just a pinch
and then you lead that horse to water
what do you think that horse does when
he sees the water
gonna drink it up you're gonna drink
that water you know he's drinking that
he's going right for that man you can't
hold him back at a certain point yeah
he's got that little bit of salt he's
thirsty
so you've enticed that circumstance you
can lead a horse to water you can't make
him drink but you sure as heck and
enticing
how can we entice muslims to come now to
learn how to have the right mindset
i had one of my guys today he's telling
me that he's thinking about suicide but
he keeps coming back with the same thing
all the time threatening people he's
going to commit suicide trying to make
them afraid
that he's going to commit suicide that
they run and do all of this stuff for
him i said i'm not doing it what did i
do i gave him i printed well i didn't
even print it up but i sent up a copy of
the last testament uh the last will and
testament for a muslim
i told him if you're going to commit
suicide be prepared
he got offended i was like
it doesn't matter if you're going to
commit suicide go ahead and be prepared
the prophet saw islam told us that any
muslim has anything to give you you have
two days you go ahead and make sure that
you write down your last will
so if you're going to talk about
committing suicide nobody can't stop you
if you're really committed to go ahead
and do that we have we advise you not to
because it's haram
but even if you did so we'll bury you
but then on you we have to leave you to
allow for his judgment
i mean if we're going to be real let's
be real
because we're not playing this is not a
game isn't it
for me islam is not a game islam saved
my life
he chose to save me to be able to even
come here and be before you so i could
give you this message
so
i'm here and i'm very happy to be able
to to make this contribution and get
these few things out here and to uh uh
to be with you guys man it's an honor
it's really truly a a deep and uh
serious honor for me to come i watch
your programs and and uh
i i see the effort that you guys put in
and again the the fact that you keep
showing up
80 percent of success is showing up
and you guys are showing up and you're
making a difference and you you know
here's the thing and maybe i'm talking a
lot but again i i have so much
for me i just i have so much i want to
share
here's here's the thing that i see that
you guys are doing you're making people
think
you're making people think especially
the muslims
and the good thing about that is well
okay it's a challenge but it's a good
thing because what happened now is that
two percent of people think two percent
there's three percent of people who
think that they think
and there's 95 of people who would
rather die than think they want somebody
to tell them what to do
yeah
yeah we fall into that too often man
they just want somebody to tell them
what to do they're not interested in
thinking yeah thinking doesn't even
apply to them so they just want to go
along with the program but and here's
the challenge is that everything goes on
his own little wavelength
a tv does not pick up the radio
wavelength
your cell phone does not pick up the tv
wavelength and so on and so forth the
microwave does not pick up a wavelength
of something else the refrigerator or
something everything is on its own
particular wavelength isn't it
so okay we i mean at some point in time
we have to be on a wavelength that
connects us so that there's no
disconnection
so we can have that conversation and
start to move things forward
i mean i mean i mean
okay
powerful episode
this is just me talking this is just me
talking to you brothers you know and
loving what you do and may allah bless
you and i i pray that uh you keep on
doing it
and i hope that uh i hope that uh i
haven't worn up my welcome and you'll
invite me back one day
we will inshaallah
when you get a chance when you get a
chance uh especially you know one of the
things that uh um has been um one of my
greatest blessings if we put together
you know
again the the reason why i'm that's the
reason why i'm sharing my screen is to
be able to under help people understand
that a pitcher can speak a thousand
words yeah
okay and so one of the things we did
with the youth we we used to teach them
and we still do teach them by coming out
to show them rather than just tell them
because we talk with words yeah
but when we dream or when we think we
think in pictures
yeah
huh
and what we did was we take them now to
five places and i advise you about this
what is it five places we take them to
the graveyard
to the jail
to the homeless shelter the mental
institution back to the mosque
you want to get their attention
yeah yeah put it in front of them
don't let them slip away
it's probably going to take you a few
hours but if you can get them to those
five places tell you right now man we've
had seven out of ten young people and
even some of the adults who went with us
on this particular we call it a social
awareness tour it's on youtube
social awareness tour
and when we have seven out of ten people
who want with us on this thing they they
leave whatever they were doing
the corruption and the filth and the
drugs and the violence and the crime and
the gangs and all the other kind of
stupidness
they get they're stuck on stupid and
then when we show them the reality of
where they can end up these four places
will take you any time you want 24 hours
a day
if you mess up here's where you end up
this place is open for your guidance and
benefit 24 hours a day or at least in
some cases there
islam is there for you
but you have to come and take it you
have to come and want it you have to be
making dua
you have to be asking allah for it
so this and this i don't know if uh i'm
hoping that i'm hoping the message i'm
sharing with you is getting through
because this is for me this is how i
operate but some people wanted they they
want to come and say oh brother i want
to work with you but then when they get
here they say oh but hold on brother
you're being too strict you're being too
harsh well okay i'm not your guy
if you're not actually ready to make
progress i am not your guy
for me i'm working with people in jail
who want to solve their problems drug
addicts who want to solve their problems
homeless people who want to solve their
problems if you're not one of those
people who want to solve your problems
with islam then how can i help you yeah
yeah that's true
perhaps some people come to you because
they think you can solve their problems
and when they realize they have to know
their problems yeah
you may be right about that brother i i
didn't even look at that aspect of it
but for me i'm not interested in trying
to solve the problem i'll show them how
they for me i i can do it with you but i
can't do it for you but i'll show you
how you can do it with your islam yes ma
brothers and sisters link in the
description to book your consultation
with ibrahim downey click the link in
the description down below and until
next time you put in the link for uh uh
uh gabriel's um
gabriel's uh
uh positive what is it positive positive
yeah i'll put your i'll put your link
inshaallah okay i appreciate that
jazakallah oh yeah
but okay listen but okay just one thing
i'll do respect don't call them if
you're not serious if you're just
following the chat we'll have a good
chat but again when it comes to the work
we're going to have a problem
because the rubber meets the road real
quick with the stuff that we're doing
it's called empowerment training for a
reason
you get up and you do what it takes to
be able to make the moves if you're not
willing to make the moves
we're going to have a problem i mean
we don't necessarily have to have a
problem because again you can take the
choice not to work with me but i can
also take the choice not to work with
you
so let's go ahead and deal with that
because again for me i i love to put in
the work but i want the commitment to
come from the other side too because i'm
not me my family came out of slavery i'm
not interested in going back
me i'm the slave of allah
after that
you got to figure out how to work with
me
not get me to work for you
masha allah masha allah i think that's a
beautiful note to end off on
inshallah
i want to recommend that for you guys
when you're ending your thing uh make
sure that you if you can say that
because again uh the this one blesses
all of the things that you did
it gives a certain blessing and it
tightens it and if there's anything
wrong then allah
easily forgives it
all right insha allah i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to learn it and
everything
okay
allah has already blessed me man i mean
being out here with you guys is a big
deal for me brother this is going in my
legacy program now the next time i want
to show you guys about the empowerment
wheel
you guys will love the empowerment wheel
so don't wait forever to get me back on
here
all right bye even with that being said
to all the lovely viewers
of plum please and pleasure
i was waiting on honor to
to scream again you mean cream
no scream
you
your drink was screaming bro
that's true yeah you just took a cipro
on camera i'll take another one
say bismillah bro what are you doing
well it's in my head man it's the whole
like i think there's another thing too
it's it's the perseverance aspect too
like we're more willing to stick through
with things that we set out with an
intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first of
all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends you
want to be investing stocks shares bonds
you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza
we will go in with our final three with
brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]